the answer the question is no China will
be able to pull itself out of the
financial crisis indeed it has already
done so showing very strong growth but
nearly all about 19 5 percent of all the
demand growth in China is actually going
into output of moonshine so it is
affecting the Chinese economy
dramatically the spillover effect on to
the rest of the world is going to be
relatively modest it might add to the
rest of the world's out but perhaps a
tenth of a percent of GDP or two tenths
of a percent of GDP not enough to be a
decisive engine in the end though China
has become the second largest economy of
the world or very close to it it's not
big enough to pull the world as a whole
that requires beat increases in demand
in the developed world which have
economies in aggregate about 10 times as
big as that of China so China will save
itself but not the world